let's review a little bit of what we
learned in differential calculus let's
say we have some function s that it
gives us as a function of time the
position of a particle in one dimension
if we were to take the derivative with
respect to time so if we were to take
the derivative with respect to time of
this function s what are we going to get
well we're going to get DS DT or the
rate at which position changes with
respect to time and what's another word
for that the rate at which position
changes with respect to time well that's
just velocity so that we could write it
as velocity as a function of time now
what if we were to take the derivative
of that with respect to time so we could
either view this as the second
derivative we're taking the derivative
not once but twice of our position
function or you could say that we're
taking the derivative with respect to
time with our velocity function well
this is going to be we can write this as
we can write this as D V DT the rate at
which velocity is changing with respect
to time and what's another word for that
well that's also called acceleration
this is going to be our acceleration as
a function of time so you start with the
position function take its of the
position as a function of time take its
derivative with respect to time you get
velocity take that derivative with
respect to time you get acceleration
well you could go the other way around
if you started with acceleration if you
started with acceleration and you were
to take the antiderivative if you were
to take the antiderivative of it the
aunt D an antiderivative of it is going
to be actually let me just write it this
way so an antiderivative I'll just use
the integral symbol to show that I'm
taking the antiderivative is going to be
the integral of the antiderivative of a
of T and this is going to give you some
expression with a plus C and we could
say well that's a general form of our
velocity function this is going to be
equal to our velocity function and to
find the particular velocity function we
would have to know what the velocity is
at a particular time then we could solve
for our C
but then if we're able to do that and we
were to take the antiderivative again
then now we're taking the antiderivative
of our velocity function which would
give us some expression as a function of
T and then some other constant and if we
could solve for that constant then we
know then we know what the position is
going to be the position is a function
of time just like this we would have
some plus C here but if we know our
position at a given time we could solve
for that C so now that we've reviewed it
a little bit but we've rewritten it in I
guess you could say thinking of it right
not just from the differential point of
view for the derivative point of view
but thinking of it from the
antiderivative point of view let's see
if we can solve an interesting problem
let's say that we know that the
acceleration of a particle is a function
of time is equal to 1 so it's always
accelerating at one unit per and you
know I'm not giving you time let's let's
just say that we're thinking in terms of
meters and seconds so this is one meter
per second one meter per second squared
right over here that's our acceleration
as a function of time and let's say we
don't know the velocity expressions but
we know the velocity to a particular
time and we don't know the position
expressions but we know the position at
a particular time so let's say we know
that the velocity at time three let's
say three seconds is negative three
meters per second and actually want to
write the unit's here just to make it a
little bit a little bit so this is
meters per second squared that's going
to be a unit for acceleration this is
our unit for velocity and let's say that
we know let let's say that we know that
the position at time two at two seconds
is equal to negative 10 meters so if
we're thinking in one dimension of which
is moving along the number line it's ten
to the left of the origin so given this
information right over here and
everything that I wrote up here can we
figure out the actual expressions for
velocity as a function of time
so not just velocity at time three but
velocity generally as a function of time
and position as a function of time and I
encourage you to pause this video right
now and try to figure it out on your
so let's just work through this what is
we know that velocity as a function of
time is going to be the anti derivative
the anti derivative of our acceleration
is a function of time our acceleration
is just one so this is going to be the
antiderivative of this right over here
is going to be T and then we can't
forget our constant plus C and now we
can solve for C because we know V of
three is negative three so let's just
write that down so V of three is going
to be equal to three three plus C I just
so every place where I saw the the T or
ever place where I have the T I replace
it with this three right over here
actually let me make it a little bit
clearer so V of three V of 3 is equal to
three plus C and they tell us that
that's equal to negative three so that
is equal to that is equal to negative
three so what's C going to be so if we
just look at this part of the equation
or just this equation right over here if
you subtract 3 from both sides
you get you get C is equal to negative 6
and so now we know the exact we know the
exact expression that defines velocity
as a function of time V of T V of T is
equal to T T plus negative 6 or t minus
6 and we can verify that the derivative
of this with respect to time is just 1
and when time is equal to 3 3 minus 6 is
indeed negative 3 so we've been able to
figure out velocity as a function of
time so now let's do a similar thing to
figure out position as a function of
time we know that position is going to
be an antiderivative of the velocity
function so let's write that down
so position as a function of time is
going to be equal to the antiderivative
of V of T DT which is equal to the
antiderivative of t minus 6
DT which is equal to well the
antiderivative of T is T squared over 2
so T squared over 2 we've seen that
before the antiderivative of negative 6
is negative 6t
and of course we can't forget our
constant so plus plus C so this is what
s of T is equal to s of T is equal to
all of this business right over here and
now we can try to solve for our constant
and we do that using this information
right over here at at 2 seconds where
our position is negative 10 meters so s
of 2 or I could just write it this way
let me write it this way s of 2 at 2
seconds is going to be equal to 2
squared over 2 that is let's see that's
4 over 2 that's going to be 2 minus 6
times 2 so minus 12 plus C is equal to
negative 10 is equal to negative 10 so
let's see we get 2 minus 12 is negative
is negative 10 plus C is equal to
negative 10 so you add 10 to both sides
you get C in this case is equal to 0 so
we figured out what our position
function is as well the C right over
here is just going to be 0 so our
position as a function of time is equal
to T squared over 2 minus 6t and you can
verify when T is equal to 2 2 squared
over 2 is 2 minus 12 is negative 10 you
take the derivative here you get T minus
6 and you can see and we already verify
that V of 3 is negative 3 and you take
the derivative here you get a of T just
like that anyway hopefully you found
this enjoyable